PROFESSOR: OK, so as you know,
we've moved in our discussion
to the question of what sort
of social structures are
either legitimate or
contributory to the well being
of humans, given our nature.
And we ended last lecture by
having a game theoretic
representation of what I
called the cooperation
dividend, which you'll recall
involves the case of two
individuals who, fearful that
the other will attack their
resources, expend a certain
amount of energy walling off
their goods.
Where if they were somehow to
find themselves in a situation
where they could cooperate and
trust themselves to cooperate,
their energy could be devoted,
instead of to the protection
of their goods, to
the production of
other sorts of goods.
Those required, as Hobbes says,
"for commodious living"
and for things like
navigation.
Goods that would allow both
of them to be better off.
And in the last two lectures we
looked at the writings of
Thomas Hobbes in the context of
his work, Leviathan which
explored both why it is that
the cooperation dividend is
expected to be to the advantage
of all and also why
it is that in order to hold
cooperation in place, certain
sorts of external enforcement
mechanisms--
in Hobbes's mind, a Leviathan,
a monarch or leader who has
absolute power--
is required to hold this sort
of cooperation in place.
What we're going to turn to
in the lectures today and
Thursday is a contemporary
version of this question,
which asks us to think about--
if we are considering not merely
the cooperation or lack
of cooperation between two
people, but rather the
distribution of goods and
responsibilities across a
larger community--
how it is that such a society
should be structured if we
take as our basic picture
something similar to Hobbes.
Namely the idea that cooperation
is beneficial to
all in a way that competition
isn't, but that stably
promoting cooperation requires
certain sorts of
incentivizing.
And so what we'll look in
particular today is discussion
by the 20th-century philosopher
John Rawls who
lived from 1921 to 2002 and
who taught at Harvard
throughout his career.
We encountered Rawls writings
already in a very early paper,
the 1955 paper on punishment
that we looked at where he
introduced the idea of a
two-level justification of
punishment.
And what we'll be looking at in
today's lecture is Rawls'
discussion in his enormously
influential 1971 book, A
Theory of Justice.
So Rawls' Theory of Justice,
which in many ways brought
back into contemporary
philosophical discussion
consideration of a set of
questions which we traced all
the way back to Plato's
Republic --
why is it in people's self
interest to participate in a
societal structure --
and brought it back
in a way that
entered the public discourse.
A Theory of Justice is the kind
of book that you'll see
cited in legal cases.
You'll see it discussed not
merely in academic journals,
but also in intellectually
grounded conversations about
the legitimacy of the society.
And A Theory of Justice begins
with these famous words.
Rawls says, after saying what
he hopes to do in the book,
that "Justice is the first
virtue of social institutions
as truth is of systems of
thought." He says, "Just as a
theory, however elegant and
economical, must be rejected
or revised if it's untrue, so,
too laws and institutions, no
matter how efficient or well
arranged, must be reformed or
abolished if they are unjust."
This is an articulation of what
Rawls sees as the central
commitment of a certain outlook
of the legitimacy of
government.
A Western picture-- and perhaps
more general picture--
according to which, a social
structure, an arrangement of
fundamental institutions by
which lives are governed, is
legitimate if and only if the
institutions which it supports
are just.
So just as a theory which is
extraordinarily elegant but
false should be rejected on the
grounds that it's untrue,
so too, says Rawls, should a
societal structure which is
elegant but unjust
be rejected.
He goes on to identify what he
sees as some fundamental
commitments of this
sort of picture.
He writes, for example, that
"each person possesses an
inviolability founded on justice
that even the welfare
of society as a whole
cannot override.
For this reason, justice
denies that the loss of
freedom for some is made right
by a greater good shared by
others."
Now we thought about
this question--
the question of the trade-off of
goods across individuals--
in the context of our discussion
of consequentialism
on the one hand and other moral
theories, deontology and
virtue theory on the other.
What Rawls gives voice to--
both here and in sections 5 and
26 of Theory of Justice,
which I had you read --
is another reason related to the
reason that we read about
in Bernard Williams, this
idea of dignity.
Another reason for rejecting as
a fundamental way of making
sense of human responsibility,
consequentialism as its
grounding basis.
But what might not have been
apparent to you when we were
reading things like The Trolley
Problem, was the
connection of the outlook--
this idea that "each person
possesses an inviolability
founded on justice that even the
welfare society as a whole
cannot override," --
and one of the foundational
documents of this nation.
So among the truths that Thomas
Jefferson thought we
hold "to be self evident," is
that "all men are created
equal and that they are endowed
by their creator with
certain inalienable rights.
And that among these," --
these rights such that even the
utility of society as a
whole is not sufficient
to override them--
"are life, liberty and the
pursuit of happiness."
Moreover, you'll see in this
founding document--
this is of course the
Declaration of Independence--
that there is voice given to
exactly the contract-carrying
picture that we first recognize
in its inchoate form
in Glaucon's discussion of the
role of justice in Plato's
Republic and much more clearly
in the work of Hobbes.
So listen to what comes next.
"That to secure these rights,
governments are instituted
among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the
governed." The idea that
entering into a social
contract with one another --
whereby as a way securing the
rights to life, liberty and
the pursuit of happiness, we
subject ourselves to a rule of
law, which we thereby take
to be legitimate --
is central, both to the social
contract tradition as
articulated in Hobbes and his
successors, Locke and Rousseau
and Kant, and to this document,
which all of us have
presumably encountered
previously.
Moreover, continues this
document, "whenever any form
of government becomes
destructive of these ends, it
is the right of the people to
alter or to abolish it and to
institute a new government."
What kind of new government?
What's Jefferson's answer?
A new government, where "laying
its foundation on such
principles and organizing its
powers in such form as to them
shall seem most likely to
affect their safety and
happiness."
So the idea that we set out to
create a government that gains
its legitimacy through our
recognition that thereby our
self-interest is advanced is a
central notion to the American
political tradition.
So how does it manifest itself
in the particular text that
we're thinking about today?
How does John Rawls, in this
book from the 1970s, attempt
to give contemporary voice to
this set of concerns that 200
years prior to him were given
voice to by Thomas Jefferson
and 150 years prior to
that were given voice
to by Thomas Hobbes?
So Rawls begins by saying
what it is that he
takes society to be.
Society, that which we're trying
to identify a set of
characteristics for, is "a more
or less self-sufficient
association of persons, who in
their relations to one another
recognize certain rules of
conduct as binding" and who,
"for the most part, act in
accordance with them." You'll
recall that at the end of the
Prisoners' Dilemma lecture
last week and also in our
readings for last Thursday, we
looked at mechanisms other
than the ones that Hobbes
identified for enforcing
social contract.
Hobbes thought the most
effective way was the
imposition of a sovereign, whose
threat of penalty and
punishment would hold people
to behave in certain ways.
But it turns out that in
addition to that, the taking
on implicitly through conscience
or habit of certain
kinds of norms of interaction
ends up playing as great if
not larger a role in allowing
societies to function smoothly.
And in next Tuesday's readings
we'll look at some social
psychological work
that directly
addresses that question.
So Rawls has told us what it is
that he thinks a society is
for the purposes
of discussion.
It's "a more or less
self-sufficient association of
persons, who in their relations
to one another
recognize" something--
that is "certain rules of
conduct-- as binding" and,
"for the most part" -- not
always, I know some of you
talk on your cell phone
while you drive --
"act in accordance with them."
These rules "specify a system
of cooperation that's designed"
to do what?
It's designed to do the thing
that Thomas Jefferson was
talking about in the
Constitution.
It's designed to do the thing
that Thomas Hobbes was talking
about in Leviathan.
It's designed to do the thing
that Glaucon was talking about
in his challenge to Socrates.
They specify "a system of
cooperation that is designed
to advance the good of those
taking part of it." The
legitimacy of government on this
picture derives from the
fact that it is to the advantage
of those who
participate in it.
However--
and this is the perplexing
feature that makes political
philosophy a discipline of great
intellectual interest--
"although a society is a
cooperative venture for mutual
advantage," it is, says Rawls,
undeniably typically "marked
by conflict as well
as identity of
interests." Why is this?
It's because while there is
an identity of interests--
because social cooperation makes
possible a better life
for all than any would have if
each were to live solely by
his own efforts.
That is, we get dividends as
the result of not having to
expend our energy on protecting
ourselves from the
threat of others' harm.
Each of us-- as we know from
the last two lectures--
is better off when we can
count on others to be
cooperative.
It is nonetheless the case that
there is a conflict of
interest in any society since
"persons are not indifferent
as to how the greater benefits
of their collaboration are
distributed."
Roughly speaking, each prefers
a larger to a lesser share.
If there are cooperation
dividends, that is good and
produces a reason
for cooperation.
But when there are cooperation
dividends, each of us--
reasonably enough--
wants as many of the dividends
as we can get.
And the consequence of that is
that although "society is a
cooperative venture for mutual
advantage," it's typically
"marked by conflict as well
as identity of interests."
So this gives rise to the
next level question.
When we read Hobbes we read only
the very beginning of his
discussion of the social
contract, just a bit from the
end of book one and the very
beginning of book two.
Rawls is now turning to a
question beyond that.
Namely, what set of principles
ought we to adopt, given the
fact of conflict?
So we're taking it as a given
that we want cooperation, we
want some sort of societal
structure.
As a result we're going to end
up with more stuff than we
would have had if we hadn't
been cooperating.
How should that stuff, how
should those goods--
some tangible, some
intangible--
be distributed?
So Rawls points out that a set
of principles is required for
choosing among the various
social arrangements, which
determine this distribution
of advantages.
These principles "provide a way
of assigning rights and
duties in the basic institutions
of society."
Things like what the legal
system looks like.
Things like what the economic
Things like what the fundamental
rights and
responsibilities of citizens
look like.
And what they do it to define an
appropriate distribution of
benefits and burdens of
social cooperation.
Because, as we've already noted,
social cooperation
brings with it undeniable
benefits but it also brings
with it several kinds
of burdens.
Your freedom is restricted
in certain ways in
a cooperative system.
And it may well be the case that
the benefits that accrue
to the social system
go to someone else.
So we're now at a point where
I will give voice to what
Rawls calls the main idea of
the theory of justice.
And then I'm going to explain to
you how that fits with his
notion of the veil
of ignorance.
And then just as your attention
is beginning to
flag, we're going to
do some clickers.
So hold up, a little more
fact and then some fun.
So the main idea of The Theory
of Justice is, as I've pointed
out to you already, something
that is part of the social
contract tradition.
Rawls explicitly says in the
first footnote of the text
that we read for today that he's
working primarily from
the social contact picture as
articulated in Locke, Rousseau
and Kant, but that he
is harkening back
to Hobbes in it.
And this, as you know, is the
following idea, that each of
us recognizes that there's a
certain advantage to living in
a society where we're not
constantly under threat, that
each recognizes that non-threat
can be achieved--
this idea that you're not
constantly at risk in this
cold war of all against all.
But non-threat can be achieved
only under general
cooperation.
And that general cooperation
can be achieved only under
some sort of implicit or
explicit enforcement system.
So Rawls, with that social
contract framework in mind,
goes on to ask, what would it
take to get a clear picture of
what that enforcement system
ought to look like if, as we
recall, it's meant to be
something, which is for the
good of each of its
participants?
And here is what he says.
He says, "The principles of
justice," of the basic
structure of society, "are those
that free and rational
person concerned to further
their self-interest would
accept in an original position
of equality as defining the
fundamental terms of
their association"
That is there are four
fundamental ideas that
underlie this picture.
The rules that govern your
society, the rules that govern
a legitimate society, into which
you ought to contract,
are rules that you would accept
if you were free,
rational, self-interested and in
a position of equality with
respect to all of the other
free, rational and
self-interested individuals who
are also contracting into
this society.
How can we possibly get there?
How can we possibly determine
what free, rational,
self-interested and equal
individuals would agree to,
given that--
as a matter of fact--
we're not all equal?
Some of us were born into
families of wealth and some of
us were born into families
of poverty.
Some of us were born with
certain sets of natural
talents; others were born
with other sets.
Some of us were born with
certain sorts of conceptions--
or some of us were raised
to have certain sorts of
conceptions--
of the good life.
Others of us were raised
to have others.
Rawls' idea is this: the
principles that articulate the
legitimate structure of society
are those to which you
would agree if you did not know
which person you were
going to be.
So he asks you to imagine that
you sit behind what's he
called a "veil of ignorance,"
where no one knows his place
in society, his class position,
his social status,
his fortune in the distribution
of natural assets
and abilities, his intelligence,
his strength or
his conception of the good.
From this position, where you
don't know which person you
are going to be, you get
the fourth of our four
requirements.
You get equality.
Because nothing in particular
about your self-interest will
play a role.
And having put yourself in this
imaginary position, where
ignorance brings with it a
certain kind of ability to
think clearly about the
question, each party then
freely determines on the basis
rational self-interest. So
that gives us freedom,
rationality and self-interest.
The framework that they
think would be best.
So the idea is this: a bunch of
people who don't know what
role they will play in society
sit behind the veil of
ignorance and think, how would
I want society to be
structured if I didn't know
whether I was going to end up
as a shepherd or a capitalist or
a doctor or a construction
worker or a police officer or
someone who has difficulties
with the authority of police
officers or somebody who's
differently abled or
perhaps even as a
Yale football player?
And from behind this veil of
ignorance, recognizing that
any one of these identities
could end up being the one
that they would have, these
individuals come up with a
framework for how it is that
society would be structured.
So recognizing that they might
be extraordinarily wealthy,
they may take into consideration
what it would
take for society to allow
individuals to flourish under
those conditions.
But they might recognize at the
same time that they might
end up as one of the
construction workers.
Perhaps they would end
up as a doctor.
Perhaps the set of abilities
that they had would differ
from those of the majority
of the society and so on.
So what you have in the
articulation of the veil of
ignorance as a way of thinking
about this question, is Rawls'
version of a theme that we have
seen over and over and
over again in this course.
Hobbes says to you: When you
think about political
structures, think about
yourself as not being
different from everyone else.
Be willing, he says, "to lay
down your rights to the extent
that others are willing
to do this the same.
Content yourself with as much
liberty against others as
others have against you."
Mill says, "Actions are right in
proportion as they tend to
promote happiness, wrong as
they tend to produce the
reverse of happiness.
Not the agent's own happiness,
but the happiness of all
concerned." And Kant, again
giving voice to this idea: --
When you think from the moral
perspective do not think of
yourself as special. --
writes, "Act only in accordance
with that maxim
through which you can at the
same time will that it will
become a universal law."
So if you will take out your
clickers, we'll do three quick
exercises where we look
to see whether
Rawls's strategy works.
So let me explain to
you how this goes.
In this case, you are deciding
whether to enroll in one of
three sections of a course.
So the lectures of the course
will be identical
in all three cases.
But in option number one the
course has four excellent
sections, sections that
earn a 9/10 on
average student ratings.
So four of the sections are
excellent and one of the
sections is terrible.
And you don't know which
section you're
going to end up in.
So in the first option you have
the choice of going to
the class and then you're going
to be randomly assigned
to one of sections.
Four of them are excellent;
one of them is terrible.
The second option is that you
can take the course and four
of the sections are
very good--
they gave a score of
7/10 on average--
and one of the sections
in terrible.
And you don't know which section
you're going to be in.
So if you take that, you have
a 4/5 chance of being in a
very good section, but you have
a 1/5 chance of being in
a terrible one.
And in the third version of
the course, four of the
sections are very good.
They get a 7/10.
And one of the sections
is so-so.
So the question is, which
course do you take?
Do you sign up for the course
that has four excellent and
one terrible section?
Remember you don't know which
section you'll be in.
Do you sign up for the course
that has four very good and
one terrible section?
Or do you sign up for the course
that has four very good
and one so-so section?
So is everybody clear on the
structure of the question?
And I'll start the voting.
OK.
All right, so let's go.
Let's see.
All right so, 60% percent
of you are with-- wow!
Where are my outliers?
Dudes!
Everybody understood!
Amazing!
We have never--
for those visitors who are
here-- we have never in this
class had 0% percent
of people choose my
obviously irrational choice.
So I'm glad to see that showing
off for non-Bulldog
days, people are doing
a good job.
So roughly 60% of you
are risk-takers.
You're willing to take the 1/5
chance of being in the
terrible class.
But 40% of you are risk-averse
in this context.
Let's try it again.
Exact same question,
different scenario.
So here's the scenario: you are
entering a housing lottery
and you can enter lottery one,
lottery two or lottery three.
Housing lottery one, there are
four excellent and one
terrible room.
Housing lottery two, there are
four very good and one
terrible room.
And housing lottery three, there
are four very good and
one so-so room.
Again, you don't know where
you will end up.
Question, do you enter housing
lottery one, housing lottery
two or housing lottery three?
And let's set the timer.
Six, five, four, three,
two, one.
And let's see what we get.
So, ha!
You guys don't care about class
but you're very risk
averse on housing.
So when it comes to your
well-being in terms of the
infrastructure in which you
live, 68% of you are willing
to forgo the possibility of
an excellent room for the
certainty that you won't end up
in a room that is terrible.
So let's try it one more time.
Now you're going
to a hospital.
And here's the configuration.
Hospital one: four excellent,
one terrible doctor.
Hospital two, four very good,
Hospital three, four very
good, one so-so doctor.
You're asking the ambulance
to take you to the ER.
You don't know which doctor
is on duty but you do know
Hospital one has four excellent,
one terrible.
Hospital two has four very
good, one terrible.
Hospital three has four
very good, one so-so.
And let's see how the numbers
come out on this.
So, four, three, two, one.
And let's see where you
placed yourselves.
So when it comes to high-stakes
medical decisions,
you are even more risk averse
than you were with housing.
How much more important than any
of these local decisions
is the global decision, what
sort of societal framework do
you want around you if you don't
know what role you will
play in it?
So Rawls's question, which
society do you choose, is
meant to be a version of those
three questions, which I just
posed to you.
Which medical system do you
choose if you don't know what
kind of individual you're
going to be?
And the answer was, you chose
one that topped out at very
good but bottomed
out at so-so.
What housing system
so you choose?
What education system
do you choose?
Those were special cases of the
question Rawls is asking.
What society do you choose from
behind the veil of ignorance?
And Rawls is very clear that
the society that you choose
has two basic commitments.
The first is that when we are
contracting into a social
framework that will govern all
aspects of our lives, the very
first condition is that within
that framework each person is
to have an "equal right to the
most extensive total system of
equal basic liberties that is
compatible with a similar
system of liberty for all." That
is, that each of us is to
have equal rights to vote,
rights to hold public office,
freedom of speech, freedom
of assembly, liberty of
conscience, freedom of thought,
freedom of person,
right to hold property and
freedom to be treated equally
with respect to the
rule of law.
These, says Rawls, are
non-negotiable and they're
non-negotiable in the sense that
if we offered you, from
behind the veil of ignorance,
the possibility of trading off
some of these goods for the sake
of utility, if you did
not know which individual you
were going to be in that
society you would not
make that trade.
This is the way in which Rawls
attempts to derive those
inviolable principles, which we
saw at the beginning of The
Declaration of Independence,
from the idea that these are
lines in the sand that would
be drawn in any social
framework to which free,
rational, self-interested,
equal parties would sign on.
So that's Rawls's first answer
to the question, which society
do you choose?
You choose one that has a
non-negotiable baseline right
at the level of so-so or better,
with respect to these
fundamental liberties.
These are things that don't get
traded off for anything.
In addition--
and somewhat more
controversially--
says Rawls, you would, behind
the veil of ignorance,
subscribe to a societal
structure where the
distribution of social and
economic inequalities followed
a certain set of constraints.
The first is, to the extent
that social and economic
inequalities arise in that
society, they need to be
attached to positions and
offices that are open to all
under conditions of fair
equality of opportunity.
If attending an outstanding
educational institution will
increase the likelihood that you
can go on to have a job,
whereby you gain fulfillment
and earn a disproportionate
share of society's resources,
then it needs to be the case,
says Rawls, that those
positions, those
opportunities, are open to all
regardless of contingencies of
circumstance that are irrelevant
to the possibility
of their making use of them.
In particular, your family's
financial resources shouldn't
play a role in your ability to
access these opportunities.
So fair equality of opportunity
is the first
condition that Rawls thinks
needs to hold in order for
social and economic inequalities
to be acceptable
to you from behind the veil of
ignorance when you do not know
who you will be.
In addition, and even more
controversially, Rawls thinks
that behind the veil of
ignorance it would be agreed
by the parties that social and
economic inequalities would be
accepted as legitimate only
to the extent that those
inequalities are to the
advantage of all.
And, in particular, to the
advantage of those who are
least well off.
So Rawls does not deny that a
rising tide lifts all boats,
that there may well be cases
where allowing discrepancies
in income or resources or
educational opportunities or
the quality of health
care would--
as a matter of fact--
lead everybody to
be better off.
Perhaps the fact that there are
research hospitals is of
great value, even to those who
don't have direct access to
those hospitals.
Nonetheless, it is because,
and only because, those
inequalities benefit the least
well off that Rawls thinks
they would be agreed to behind
the veil of ignorance.
Moreover, Rawls thinks that
these principles, which I've
articulated--
the first principle, the equal
liberty principle, and the
second principle, which tells us
the conditions under which
inequality is legitimate--
are what he calls "lexically
ordered" so that no
utilitarian trade-offs
are permitted.
In particular, there is no
trading freedom for utility.
If it would be advantageous to
society as a whole to engage
in a certain sort of racial
profiling, for example, to
reduce crime but in so doing
the liberties of a certain
group would be impinged upon,
that utility consideration is
not sufficient, says Rawls
More over, as I've pointed
out, on Rawls's picture,
inequality is permitted only
when the advantage goes to the
least well off.
So in the last three, four
minutes of class, I want to do
two more polls with you.
So if your clickers are
available, I want to see what
your thoughts are on this.
And if your thoughts diverge
from Rawls, I'm going to give
you four places to identify
the locus of disagreement.
So let's start with this.
You're trying to choose
among societies.
Society one has an average
income of $100,000 and 85% of
its citizens have the right to
vote and have freedom of
conscience and religion
and the like.
That is, this is a society in
which 15% of people lack basic
civil rights but the average
income is $100,000.
Society number two has an
average income of $70,000 and
15% of the people lack
basic rights.
Society number three has an
average income of $70,000 but
100% of the people have basic
freedoms. You're behind the
veil of ignorance.
You do not know whether you
will be among the 15% in
society one or two.
As a matter of free, equal,
self-interested rationality,
which society do you choose?
One, two, or three.
And let's see how these
numbers come out.
It looks like the lexical
priority of the first
principle over the second is one
over which there isn't a
great deal of controversy.
Let's try the difference
principle.
Three societies.
You don't know who
you will be.
Society one: average
income of $100,000.
Lowest income: $10,000.
Society number two: average
income $70,000,
lowest income, $10,000.
Society number three: average
income is $70,000, lowest
income, $20,000.
You do not know who
you will be.
Which society do you choose?
And let's see how the
numbers come out on
the difference principle.
OK.
So, still, huh.
Not as much difference
as I had expected.
Interesting to see, that most
of you-- even here--
are egalitarian.
Averse to an increase in the
average if is at the cost to
the least advantage.
So for those of you who are in
the 27% here and for those of
you more generally who aren't
accepting the Rawlsian
framework, I want to point out
four different places where
you might be stepping
away from him.
The first is that you may
disagree with him about what
sorts of principles
would be chosen
behind the veil of ignorance.
You might think that
maximin reasoning--
remember in section 26 he
says, behind the veil of
ignorance, people would
be risk-averse.
They would distribute goods in
such a way that they benefited
the least well off.
So you might deny that behind
the veil of ignorance the
principles that Rawls
says would be
chosen would be chosen.
You might deny that it's the
choice that one make behind
the veil of ignorance that
represents what free, equal,
rational and self-interested
persons would accept as
fundamental terms of
their association.
That is, you might think the
veil of ignorance is not an
effective device of
representation for answering
the question which Rawls
sets out to answer.
Or you might think that
what free, rational,
self-interested equal persons
would accept as fundamental
terms of association is what
the veil of ignorance gives
you, but that doesn't determine
what's just.
Or you might think--
and we'll consider this answer
in our lecture on Thursday--
that it's not the case that
the first virtue of social
institutions is justice.
But rather that there are
other values even more
fundamental that lie at the
center of political
legitimacy.
And we'll turn to
that question in
our lecture on Thursday.